>>Jeff Finch: Not only do we integrate
technology to the best of our ability,
but also we integrate the idea
of instructional coaching.
And we've found that
this pays dividends.
>>Andrew Halter: It is important
that the idea comes before the tools.
You need to have a good solid
instructional idea and then find
out how you can enhance
it with technology.
>>Jeff Finch: As a coach we
asked them to meet with teachers
and understand the big ideas.
What are your instructional goals?
What competencies do you want
to see these students perform?
>>Andrew Halter: How do you hope the
technology would enhance the relevance?
Does the technology allow students to
collaborate beyond the classroom walls?
Does the technology allow for
a certain kind of transparency
so a teacher can see more individually
how a student is perceiving a concept.
When you start to look at all of
these new technological approaches
and you can't wrap your mind them, when
you have someone else who can lead you
through the process,
show you some examples
that other teachers have
created that were successful,
it helps people kind of
bridge that resistance.
>>Gregory Mihalik: When the school it
was already into utilizing technology
in a classroom, I was a
little behind everybody.
>>Andrew Halter: Yeah, so you
could use the Flubaroo to grade it.
>>Gregory Mihalik: Right.
>>Gregory Mihalik: Obviously, it could
uncomfortable situation for students
to talk about certain topics
in our wellness class.
This is an STD project.
>>Andrew Halter: We had the
students design their own websites
to teach peers about a specific STD.
>>Rachel: Doing multimedia with
pictures and good statistics can really,
I think, make people listen more.
>>Andrew Halter: On our project tips
page we have "How to create videos",
different ways that they can
actually create a cartoon character.
They do pressies, which
are kinda Powerpoints.
>>Andrew Halter: If you're using a
graphic that has a lot of text on it,
Animoto brings it up so fast that if
it's a graphic that somebody needs time
to think about and interpret, put it
on the wiki instead of on the Animoto.
>>Andrew Halter: They're pulling in
from various sources and they have
to transform that content into
something that is visually engaging
and is presented in a way
that will reach students.
>>Andrew: We just have to create a wiki
space that explains it and we present it
to our class and then they have to
fill out a quiz based on our research.
Well, for me, at least this is our first
time creating a quiz for our peers.
So it's kinda cool.
It's intriguing.
>>Gregory Mihalik: And this has gone
from kids being timid and not wanting
to even raise their head in
class and make eye contact
because of the things
we're talking about to
where you see them take ownership
in it and have fun with it.
As far as technology, you
know, it got to the point
where I became more comfortable with it.
It's had an effect that
I want it to have.
So it was worth it.
>>Andrew Halter: There's no definite
mandate of who I'm going to work with.
It's really based on teacher need.
Sometimes I'm just there to help
support them, give them ideas
and let them run with it themselves.
A lot of times it'll
be to map out a lesson
that we will be teaching together.
>>Gregory Mihalik: The whole point
of the lesson is to introduce them
to themes and the history on "The Great
Gatsby" so they can look at the pictures
and interpret them as a warm-up.
>>Andrew Halter: Maybe we could
do three-two-one with them--
three observations you have, two
questions you have about what you see
in this photo, and one
connection you can make with today.
Putting this in an EarPod will be easy
once we have all the images collected,
which will let them zoom in on them
and they can really examine
the group of pictures.
>>Gregory Mihalik: In the novel
there's the three different sections
of New York that are based on wealth.
>>Andrew Halter: Okay.
>>Gregory Mihalik: So that
could be the transition
into the distribution of wealth.
>>Andrew Halter: Do you want
to do a survey with them, then?
>>Gregory Mihalik: It
would be interesting
to get a graphic of their beliefs.
>>Andrew Halter: As soon as they
respond you get a nice pie chart--
>>Gregory Mihalik: Yeah.
>>Andrew Halter: And you can
shoot that back out to them,
which really gives good discussion, but
you can do it one question at a time.
>>Gregory Mihalik: That's great.
I say yes.
>>Andrew Halter: I kind of act
as a conduit of best practices.
I take one idea from one teacher,
bring it to another teacher.
I help them with relevance
ideas as well.
Teachers don't have to know themselves
all the ins and out of how things work,
but they need to understand
the collaborative tools
that are available to students.
There're ways that they can create a
lesson to engage these different types
of learners who've grown
up with technology.
>>Teacher: You can all pull
up everyone's work as they go.
You're sharing your work with the group,
you're asking questions
and you're discussing.
>>Trace: Teachers don't try to push
some kind of technology project
on you just to say they did.
And whenever they use
it, it makes sense,
it's beneficial to what we're learning.
>>Jeff Finch: I took a teacher
who was very creative and put him
in a coaching position where
he was freed of the bell.
He could continually explore the use of
technology and then co-plan all the way
through to teaching and reflection.
It is building our capacity
for collaboration.
It is building our capacity to
integrate things thematically
and we're seeing the threads
that connect us as educators.